moi j'habite au grand bosquet donc
forcément je suis au courant du projet
de rénovation mais je viens de découvrir
qu'il avait complètement changé les
nouveaux logements qui sont prévus ils
ont plus la capacité d'accueillir de
famille nombreuse
tout un quartier c'est pour se retrouver
avec exactement les mêmes problèmes on
parle de quoi exactement des problèmes
sanitaires problèmes scolaires
d'insécurité droit défunt on parle de
quoi exactement
on a la plus grosse concentration
d'étrangers
tu dois pas comment ça se passe dehors
ou quoi toi
[Musique]
ça fait des années que la mairie va
expulser je vois pas virer des gens le
jour de Noël
[Musique]
c'est très bien quoi qu'on fasse son
passera toujours pour la racaille qui
vandalisme
on peut pas être que en colère on peut
pas
faire toujours les mêmes gouverner c'est
à nous d'agir
et toi comment tu te définirais moi
c'est une française d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]